Is that working?
Great.
Hi!
I'm super excited to be here and speaking
at
JSConf.
My name is Mariko.
That's my Twitter handle.
I should be
automatically tweeting this slide, linked
to this slide, so if you're in the
back and you want to see that, you can find
it there.
I will be joining a
company called (inaudible) next week, which
-- I'm super excited about that.
But today I'm not going to talk about software
engineering.
I'm going to
talk about knitting.
And just in case you're wondering, like if
you are
at the wrong conference, I will assure you
that I will have enough math and
code examples for you to be interested.
Just for the guideline, I have a
visual relation down on the slide.
So the blue dots are indications that
the slide has some kind of math reference,
computer science reference.
The radius of the circle is how many scoops
of ice cream I served myself after
I figured that out.
The yellow dots are some random GIF animations,
because why not?
So I like knitting.
I've been doing knitting for quite a
while.
I think the first time I was doing it I was
seven years old.
It's
something I've always done.
Once a year, come winter, I knit a scarf or
mitten.
Something very simple.
Nothing crazy like having an Etsy store or
anything.
So here's a few of my projects that I've done
in recent years.
One
winter, I think three years ago, was a very
special winter for me,
because I learned to JavaScript while I was
also working on this green scarf
project.
And I started to notice really interesting
power of
computer programming and the process of knitting.
So, for example, when you
get started -- like, if you've never knit
something, knitting might
look like this.
Seven-year-old me was like -- I'm never going
to be able to
figure this out, this thing that mom and Grandma
is doing.
So intimidating.
My experiences programming, the first time,
was just installing NPM install
on a terminal.
It was so confusing.
Words flying around, and is my laptop
being hacked?
And like what's going on?
But we all know that once you've done it,
once, and know, like, what
exactly it's doing, you know, it's not so
scary at all.
The other thing --
computer programming is very binary.
Knitting is very binary.
The atomic
unit, the smallest unit that you can do is
two stitches, which is knit
stitch and purl stitch.
Knit stitch is the stitch that you pull the
yarn from
the back of the loop, and purl stitch is the
yarn -- you push the yarn
in front of the loop.
And those two stitches create two distinct
faces
of fabric.
And the combination of those two, much like
we say -- programming
is ones and zeroes -- creates a pattern in
the fabric.
So the green side
of the fabric, which is 2x2 ribbing, which
is commonly used for the cuff
of your sweater or the neckline of your sweater,
is two knit stitch, two
purl stitch, alternating each other, and then
going row by row.
The other
side of the pattern is the one I took from
my sweater, which is a little
more intricate, making a diagonal line.
But if you look closely, it's just
knit and purl stitch.
Just one stitch by one stitch, shifting to
the
left to create a diagonal line.
Knitters have a Github, actually.
It's
called Ravelry.
People log in, you can put your patterns,
sell your
patterns, star somebody's projects, and show
your photos.
It's a central
repository of knowledge that you do with knitting.
And speaking of a central
repository, code for knitting -- the knitting
pattern -- looks like this.
And I thought this was totally -- looked like
code.
Because there is,
like, some letters that are kind of repeating,
and maybe kind of like a
variable, that's accessing the same information
again and again.
And
there's more explicit loop indications.
Like knit until two stitches
remaining.
Or repeat row one to four, for ten times.
This brings me to --
I could pseudoknit in JavaScript.
So I took this code, which was a scarf
pattern, very simple scarf pattern, put it
into 30 lines of JavaScript, to
visualize what this would look like, virtually.
And this is what I came
out.
You know, it is...
It turned out it's only using a knit stitch.
It's
not a purl stitch.
So it's okay.
And it's a knit scarf.
So making a
triangular shape.
Which is all right.
I can understand that.
So I
actually knit that pattern myself, and I have
it here.
But it turns out it didn't quite become triangular.
Instead, it
became like an arc.
So in my code, those yellow stripes should
be straight,
flat lines.
But then it became an arc.
And I was like...
This is only 30
lines of JavaScript.
And I write JavaScript professionally.
Like, where
is my bug?
I can't figure that out.
So I have it here.
Where my four
stitches started here, two inches or so, and
I knit it down.
And if I
force the fabric to see it, you could say
this is like a straight line, but
in fact, it ended up being an arc of a scarf.
So why?
I did a little bit of
research and found out that what I was discovering
was something called
hyperbolic geometry in math.
And I was like...
Okay.
In knitting, we call it ruffles.
So I did some more research, and there
were three kinds of geometry to describe,
and they both use one perfectly
straight line.
The one we're familiar is Euclidean space,
which -- you have a
baseline, and then parallel to that, you have
another line that will
never meet the baseline again.
So it's very 2D.
The other one is spherical
space, where the straight lines are on the
sphere.
However you place it, it
will always meet each other.
And the third one is a hyperbolic space, which
-- there is a baseline, and the straight line,
infinite number of straight
lines, can be drawn.
And it turns out this hyperbolic geometry
is a
hard problem to solve in computer graphics,
because it's hard to model.
Researcher at Cornell actually created a physical
model of hyperbolic
geometry in knitted fabric.
In her case, created in crotchet.
And here's her
paper about how she created the hyperbolic
plane.
So when I discovered this,
I just stumbled upon a problem making ruffles.
But when I discovered this is
an actual math problem behind my ruffle, I
was like -- this is great.
I
want to do more of this.
I want to discover more about pattern making,
and I
want to do this.
The problem was that knitting is a very slow
process.
Like,
this scarf -- itself, take maybe five days
of solid work.
So...
Eight
hours a day?
And if you think about software engineer salary
-- this is
a very expensive piece of scarf.
So I did more research about -- how can I
test out my patterns?
And stumbled upon this thing, called a knitting
machine.
Which I have never knew that this existed.
But apparently it
existed for home use, available to your house,
since 1890.
And this is the ad from that era.
And furthermore, interesting, as a native
Japanese, was that the knitting machine was
a very popular thing to own in the
household, in the '70s and '80s Japan.
And people were offering local
classes, people owned a knitting machine like
you would own a sewing machine.
I found one TV commercial on YouTube about
this knitting machine from 1979.
If you can get the audio.
(song in Japanese with female vocalist)
(male narrator speaking Japanese)
(female vocalist singing in Japanese)
All right.
So I am as confused as you are to see this
TV commercial for
one different reason.
The song that was in the background, the lyrics
said
that creating a special original pattern knitwear
is like sending a secret
love letter to your loved one.
And I thought that was kind of creepy, but
apparently...
Things to do in the '70s!
I lived in New York City when I
discovered this, so I couldn't really go down
to local classes.
So I don't
even know if that's offered in Tokyo now.
But I made a short trip to eBay.
Spent a couple hundred dollars to buy this
machine.
And I got it, I
set it up, and I was like...
Okay.
I'm going to set this up.
And create all
of the patterns, and I'm going to be awesome,
and create sweaters.
Turns
out...
Operating the machine, even before going into
creating a pattern,
was a lot of work.
The machine was made in the '80s.
It was sitting in somebody's closet for a
long time.
It was missing the manuals.
So I ended up -- the next two months,
just researching all kinds of stuff on Japanese
blog posts about machine
knitting.
Possibly watched every single YouTube video
about machine
knitting that's posted.
Many of them are Japanese.
Occasional trip to a free
preview version of Google books, because I
couldn't go to a Japanese
bookstore down the street from my parents'
house and pick up the book.
I
never thanked myself enough to be able to
speak Japanese.
Because all of
the stuff, great stuff, was available in Japanese.
And I just get to angry,
when software only offers documentation in
English.
Certain things I
could not understand.
But in knitting, at least I got my turn to
just do
things in Japanese.
On top of figuring out how to operate the
machine, I
actually needed to fix the machine.
So I figured out how to operate this
machine.
Moving back and forth.
But it wasn't knitting quite right.
Something was missing.
And basically I flipped the carriers, looking
at
examining what exactly it's supposed to do,
and what each path is doing.
And after looking at maybe four hours of,
like, mechanics of things, I
found out that one piece of thing was stuck
in there.
And just a jiggle --
it worked perfectly!
And so finally, I got to knit a fabric out
of the
machine.
And I was like...
This is great.
One thing about this machine is
it's known for something called Jacquard knit
or Fair Isle knit, or pattern
knit, if you're familiar with those terms.
The term Jacquard comes
directly from the Jacquard loom, which is
a different kind of machine
that creates a fabric, and uses a punch card
to input the data.
And this
punch card system, the punch card loom, became
the base of the modern
computer.
Which -- I thought this was a great discovery.
When I did the
research and learned about it, I was so excited.
So...
The machine is based
on that.
And you see on the '70s ad -- the machine
actually had a punch card
feeder.
So you create your own punch card, and then
feed it into the punch
card feeder, and that will translate the pattern
for you.
My machine is
coming from the '80s, so it is an Electroknit.
It's actually the name of
the model.
It's called the Electroknit.
And what does that mean?
It no
longer has a feeder for a bunch card.
But it has a mother board and chip and
magnetic strip.
You use an electromagnet to push and pull
the needles
automatically.
It's a lot like dot matrix printing, if you
are familiar with a dot matrix
printer.
One pixel becomes one stitch.
So in this machine's case, I feed it a
yellow and blue yarn, the needle that's pushed
forward is grabbing a
contrasting color, which is blue, and then
the needle that was left behind
is grabbing a base color, which is yellow.
That's how they create a pattern.
So that means I can create some kind of graphic
-- anything.
In this case, the
JSConf logo.
And then put it into knitted fabric.
And I was like...
I found
out how to operate this machine, I fixed this
machine.
This shouldn't be
a problem.
I'm going to do this.
Turns out it was not that easy.
Not even...
So there was so many things that you needed
to figure out.
Which is
indicated in that blue dot.
Even before you actually put the data into
the machine.
So first question
was like -- how do I even make bitmap image?
Because if you're using
Photoshop, you just load the colored photo
in, select grayscale, and
select the bitmap method, and it will automatically
feed the
bitmap for you.
But I need to do this in code.
How do I programmatically do
that?
Let's start with just learning about images,
and loading the image.
I
used a library called graphics magic and then
NPM package GM, which wraps
that library.
I actually started by using PhantomJS, creating
a
canvas in Phantom, loading the image, and
using the Phantom API to extract
all of the data, which worked fine, but it
was very slow.
And GM was
suggested to me as a faster alternative.
And it worked perfectly.
So when you load a file into GM as a text
file, this is what you get.
XY
coordinates of the pixel.
RGB value of the color, and then also the
hex value
for that color.
So all you do is a handy-dandy regexing, and
create an
array of arrays for each pixel.
So now I have RGB color for each pixel.
Let's
get on it and make it grayscale?
But how do I grayscale?
I spent two
hours just looking at a single Wikipedia page
about grayscaling, and the
engineer from Adobe confirmed that's okay.
So I'm confident about my
explanation here.
You have RGB value for each color.
In this case, pink
and green.
You find the highest value for each color.
In this case, pink,
red is the highest value.
Green, green is the highest value.
You repeat
that number, and then you get the grayscale
color.
So now you load the image in GM.
You get all of the color.
And you have
three color -- RGB value array.
You just find the max value out of the array,
and then you have an array of just the max
value.
And you can use that to
create a grayscale image.
So I was like...
This is black and white
photography.
So I can just load it in, because it's black
and white.
But
the grey scale image is actually black and
white and many shades of grey in
between.
And my machine only has two colors.
So it has to be just two colors.
Nothing in the shades of grey.
So my first upload was to split it in half.
Anything closer to white side gets white,
and anything closer to black
side gets black.
And it turns out like this.
Something like...
What came
out of a fax machine.
I wasn't really happy with that.
So I was like...
This
is my favorite game when I grew up.
When I was growing up.
And this only used, like, black and white,
and it
operated beautifully in my tiny Apple computer.
So I literally Googled Cosmic
Osmo graphics and figured out that I needed
to do something called dithering.
Which -- the Wikipedia article said it was
an intentionally applied form
of noise.
I don't really understand, but okay.
GM has built-in methods for
it.
So I did that.
It turns out better than my method.
But still...
Somewhere around the area is missing a definition.
And I wasn't quite happy
with it.
I did more research, and something -- discovered
that the thing I
needed to do was something called ordered
dithering, or half tone
screening, which is used for newspapers to
translate that picture into
a newspaper, which is just one color of ink.
So you have a base image.
Which you extracted the value for the grayscale.
And then you have this
noise matrix part.
You laid it over.
You compare the overlapping pixels.
And
if the base image has a lower value than your
noise matrix, then it gets
zero.
If it's over, then it gets one.
And that's how you make it into two
color images.
And of course, if it's like...
One and two, you can put it
into ones and zeroes -- matrix.
Here's a few examples of that noise matrix.
And a lot of people explore their
own matrix to create a better dithered image.
I ended up using Bayer,
because I like the output most.
So now I loaded the JSConf logo and
outputted it as ones and zero pictures.
And if I replace the zero with no
value and one with asterisk, you can see something
like this.
And it's
starting to look like something on the knitted
fabric.
So I'm like --
great.
I've got files.
Let's just put it into the machine and just
knit.
Let's make knitting pattern files.
The file format for this is something
called .dat.
Which I think stands for digital audio tape?
No idea.
If you
open it up, you get ones and zeroes.
Okay.
Great.
Binary file.
Just replace
my one and zero matrix and put it in.
But I found out if the pattern is in
there, it's actually hex.
So I'm like...
Something needs to be done in my one
and zero matrix.
Into this file.
What do I do?
There was one guy, Steve Conklin, who is writing
the same kind of project in
Python.
So I studied his code, and discovered this
line.
And at the time, I
was a newbie Python developer.
So I was learning Python.
And I'm like...
What is this?
I just went through Python's tutorial.
Nothing was
mentioned about bitwise operator.
How could I not have heard of this?
I just
went through training.
And I felt like this.
I also found out that the
bitwise operator existed in JavaScript, and
read an article, and still
couldn't really get what it is.
So what I concluded, after two days
of, like, you know...
Throwing balls against walls, was that this
is
like magic.
And this is my interpretation of what bitwise
operator and bit
shifting is.
So I'm going to give you two examples.
Two operations
that I use for this machine.
One is a bitwise left shift.
Left shift is a guy
or fellow who pushes you to the left.
And he's a magician, because it's a
bitwise operator.
So he has a magic hat.
So A is the small value of one.
And
let's bit shift forward to the left.
So the representation of this
small one is that.
And this left shift guy comes in, pushes you
four times
to the left, and because he is a magician,
he makes it to 16.
Like,
how...
What...
How could that happen?
Okay.
And the bitwise OR operator -- the same thing.
This person favors
one over zero, and he's also a magician.
So let's do bitwise OR, with 1 and
5.
Representation of the 1 and 5 is that.
First compares 1 and 1.
There is
only 1, so he chooses 1.
There's 0 and 0.
So there's no 1, so okay.
0.
And next one is 1 and 0.
So okay... 1.
And because it's magic, it stays as 5,
even though you just did something.
But it stays as 5.
So...
I needed to do
bitshifting, and if you're interested, I'm
happy to share the code, but my
one and zero matrix shifted into one set of
the decimal value of A, shifted
again, became one number, and then turned
that decimal number into hex,
and I can finally put it into my knitting
machine.
So now I have the file
prepared.
And put it into the machine.
And now I want to demo the machine.
Okay.
So I just turned it in.
I pre-loaded a file this morning.
I used USB to
serial port cable.
Which the tutorial of how to make is available
online.
And...
Just select...
You might not be able to see it.
But I'm selecting a
custom pattern that I created.
It says one time.
Stitch of 90.
Okay.
Start.
I changed the setting.
Make sure this is okay.
And now...
Something
interesting should happen.
(grinding noises)
See?
These needles are pushed forward.
This means that this carriage
uses magnetics to pull those needles, and
now these needles that are
pushed forward are picking up this blue yarn.
And...
(grinding noises)
All right!
Now the pattern is done.
I can just discharge this.
Take this
out.
Actually, just leave it there.
You may not be able to see it from the
front.
But it actually printed out the JSConf 2015
logo.
And after that, I'll
finish this scarf, and I can show it to you
in person, if you're
interested.
(applause)
Woo!
Oh, how kind!
Thank you!
So going into this project, I had no idea
what
I was doing.
I just wanted to do knitting.
And I discovered that knitting
and JavaScript are kind of related.
That turned into, like, finding out
about this machine, and I wanted to do this.
I had no reservation about trying
to sound smart.
This wasn't my job.
So whenever I go into a problem, I just
tweet out or send emails about it, and so
many people just jumped right
in, sending me code samples, and giving me
encouragement and all of
that.
So I just want to give a shout out.
Thank you!
And most of the code
will be available on Electroknit repo, which
right now is empty, but I promise
I will put it up.
And a subset from that project -- the part
I was
doing, the color math -- I was super interested
in it.
And I added more
features about translation between color spaces
and created a small library
for you to...
What do you call it?
Explore the color.
And that's available
on the color mixer repo, or NPM module.
So thank you!